the global movement against free trade
and capitalism that first came together
at the 1999 protests Against the World
Trade Organization coalesced around the
idea that Western Elites had led third
world Nations to get ensnared in a debt
trap as a way to coerce them into
adopting neoliberal policies when poor
Nations couldn't afford to repay what
they owed the World Bank and the
international monetary fund these
washington-based organizations agreed to
restructure the loans of debtor
countries if they would agree to move in
the direction of privatization
deregulation and free trade a policy
agenda termed shock therapy leftist
leaders like Hugo Chavez claimed that
this was part of a pattern of elite
subjugation of Latin America that
stretched all the way back to
Christopher Columbus shabbas used this
as evidence in support of Venezuela's
turn toward Cuba style socialism
political
s
Washington
this is
Columbia University's Joseph siegutz a
former Chief Economist at the World Bank
and a Nobel prize-winning critic of free
market capitalism promoted the same
narrative he blamed the Washington
consensus for pushing policies he deemed
too radical and wrong-headed to ever get
through in the U.S what is your
criticism of the World Bank in the IMF
and and all that they were doing in many
ways they were pursuing policies pushing
developing countries to have policies
that were very different from the
policies that we were working for are
supported at home I mean for instance
privatization of social security so like
generally speaking IMF programs are
designed to prevent western-style social
democracies they're designed to prevent
free health care and education they're
designed to prevent even like modest
subsidies on basic Goods unlike stegwits
Alex gladstein identifies as a classical
liberal and the human rights Foundation
where he works as Chief strategy officer
condemns the crimes committed by
socialist dictators like Chavez yet in
his recent book hidden repression how
the IMF and World Bank saw
exploitationist development gladstein
argues that the story told by the
radical left about these two
organizations is largely correct his
work over the last few years has focused
heavily on monetary colonialism or how
the U.S and European nations use their
control of Global Currency to override
the sovereignty of the poor nations in
Latin America and Africa the fix he says
is for the world to transition to
bitcoin a form of Freedom money that no
country or Corporation can manipulate or
control reason sat down with gladstein
at the Miami Bitcoin conference in May
to talk about his new book
why did you write hidden repression what
is monetary colonialism and why is it
bad
I wrote hidden repression because I had
a lot of questions about the IMF and
World Bank I
I knew that a lot of people in the
global South didn't like the IMF I knew
that I had a bad reputation
I didn't have the same view about the
World Bank I felt like most people
talked about the World Bank as a maybe a
neutral institution maybe had some
issues but generally speaking did good
things
but I started to kind of just notice
that they were tied to
certain practices and certain phenomena
that I was writing about uh most notably
monetary colonialism in West Africa I
noticed that the IMF was kind of the
instrument that the French used to kind
of impose currency devaluation on its
subject
post-colonial countries there
and I started to look around for
resources last summer and I noticed that
there was no kind of Pop econ book about
the IMF that like that was approachable
like there's no big short for the IMF
there is nothing I mean seriously
there's really nothing there's there's
the shock Doctrine and there's like
confessions of an economic Hitman which
are just not really what I needed you
know the second one is like highly
exaggerated and who knows how true it is
and they're they're just they were very
kind of one-sided political texts
so I just started to say all right well
let me dig into this and I started to
read everything I could find on the info
World Bank like lots of books tons of
jstor Articles like a lot of credit to
SCI Hub definitely support the Communist
and Kazakhstan around the scihub you can
give her Bitcoin
um to get all those free articles that
otherwise are behind this like insane
firewall
um but just tons of like jstor articles
from the 60s from the 70s from the 80s
lots of books written in the 80s and 90s
um and then there's just like it just
sort of ended there just wasn't a whole
lot of interest it seemed in these
institutions
like starting about 20 years ago it just
seemed like public interest went
elsewhere but they didn't go anywhere in
fact they became even bigger
um now they may not have the same
influence in the world economy that
maybe they had in 1975 but they're still
the largest lender of Last Resort and
the world's largest Development Bank and
China tried to copy what they did but it
never reached the same Peak that they
have
so I was like again I'll dig in and I
started to read everything I could get
you know most of it is leftist criticism
most of it's Marxist or leftist thought
but there's some really good libertarian
stuff too that was written in the 90s
especially around the 50-year
anniversary of Bretton Woods there's a
lot of retrospective conservatives too
wrote some stuff
um they were mainly focused on
their argument basically and this was
popular in the 90s was that these
institutions were like a waste of
taxpayer money that was kind of their
argument right Libertarians were saying
well
they're harmful and we shouldn't fund it
and then the leftists had a different
point of view
um
I feel like the libertarian and
conservative arguments are incomplete is
what I started to realize in my in my
mind
that that they weren't just inefficient
and wasteful in fact that's not accurate
I started to realize that IMF and World
Bank were incredibly lucrative for
creditor Nations like the US Germany the
UK Japan France and that they really
delivered
big big benefits for the Creditor
Nations and and I started to realize
that uh the aid and assistance that I
had thought about like I just had this
natural
kind of inkling that rich countries like
gave Aid to poor countries and there was
an aid industry and I'd even written
about that before and I just I knew it
was corrupt and inefficient but I
thought generally like we were giving
them stuff I didn't realize that we were
stealing from them I didn't realize that
the flow of resources and money
every year goes the other way I didn't
know that so when I started to learn
about that I was very shocked and and I
wanted to know what kind of role the
infer World Bank played in that
transition and I had questions I wanted
to know why did the debt of poor
countries go exponential after 1970 like
what would happen so that's kind of what
I
started to explore with the book and
actually the reason I went down the
rabbit hole in the very first place was
the dictator stuff I was like why is I'm
failing out the most brutal dictators
that ever lived you talk about Sayer as
a really good example
um I talk about I'm going to open my
talk about Zaire tomorrow I've spent a
few minutes on it and I'm just looking
at Mobutu and I'm like okay I understand
the Cold War stuff but if the INF and
World Bank
if they're supposed to benefit poor
people I mean they often have this thing
draped on their headquarters in DC that
says end poverty
true what are they doing funding this
guy who totally impoverished their
country and then you start to realize
that's not what they're doing they're
not they're not lent creating loans for
these countries to benefit people there
they're doing it to benefit us and
that's the thesis of my book which I
realize is radical but it's it's
something I just can't shake well so
enablement is such a big theme
throughout all of this and you have the
really interesting statistic in there I
believe it is Argentina has been given
22 structural adjustment loans since
1959 by the World Bank and IMF
um just by the IMF okay just by the IMF
and yet Argentina is a place that's
experienced so much hypernation
there how does this enablement uh get
cut off and what are some of the worst
examples to be fair like the libertarian
analysis has pointed out that it's not
effective basically like it's like wait
these countries that have received so
many adjustments
they don't pay back the debt
um I think again what it misses is that
it's not a waste it's been very
effective at delivering real benefits to
the west but in any event those benefits
come in three three ways that we as
Americans let's say benefit from
institutions like the IMF and World Bank
and other kinds of lending to the to the
what we would call whatever you want to
say the third world global South
developing countries Emerging Markets
basically there's a billion people in
our world and then everybody else 6.7 or
so billion elsewhere
um the first one is interest and this is
something that I didn't even really
think about too deeply like I I don't
even know like when you're just thinking
about the IMF and World Bank maybe you
think they're charity no they're like
lenders predatory lenders basically they
charge very high interest rates
especially now I mean maybe not so much
during like the zerp era but like
certainly in the 70s and today
I mean there's also a spread like they
like rich countries Park money there and
they get paid for the pleasure at a rate
and then there's a much higher rate
that's charged to the poor countries so
there's this cantal on effects thing
where the countries that are closest to
printing the money
they benefit and and the countries that
are further away have to pay more and I
know you can explain some of that around
geopolitical risk and everything but
it's it's a big big part of the system
so there's the first thing we get is
interest payments so billions of dollars
a year
flow in in interest and and repaying
principal and interest from
um from the debtor countries to the
Creditor countries through IMF World
Bank and all their little arms okay so
that's that's the first thing is is
interest the second thing is cheap
resources and labor and this is part of
my thesis about how
the IMF and World Bank were originally
created to do what makes to do pretty
sensible things in the world economy
like if they were originally created to
stabilize exchange rates after after
Bretton Woods which makes sense like all
the world was pegged to the dollar which
was pegged to gold and if you fell
outside of that band of exchange rates
like the IMF would deploy Capital to
stabilize you because we wanted trade to
flow we didn't want what happened in the
30s to happen like competitive
devaluations autarkee like we didn't
want that we wanted the space to flow
that was like the idea
um
but after 71 we went on a floating Fiat
standard we no longer had a peg to the
gold so all these economists at the time
were like why is the IMF still in
business especially libertarian
economists were like what's going on
here and what really ends up happening I
think my thesis is that like again
you've got the INF created for a
reasonable cause that may work under a
sound money standard
again lender of Last Resort in case
there's a fire
and you have the World Bank as a
Development Bank to put money into
infrastructure where private Capital
doesn't want to go
and and they funded we're turning Europe
and Japan and they they stabilized
Britain as it was coming out of its
crisis and that kind of worked until you
know 1970 or so and then what you
started to see happen in the late 60s
and early 70s was like a pivot they
started to Pivot their attention to what
what poor country is basically and
that's where I think they started to
replace like what I would call the
colonial drain I mean this is like uh
what colonialism did was basically get
really cheap labor and resources from
the periphery and delivered to the core
this is something that marxists have
noticed I think it's entirely true I
think their Solutions are disastrous but
but I think their analysis is good in
terms of I mean Marx himself he observed
this like this is what big Imperial
powers do they go out to the world I
mean they think about the Conquistadors
and they find stuff like gold and silver
and Timber and oil and they steal it or
they get it for very cheap and they
bring it back so that the home country
can be enriched and so our standards of
living can be raised and that so that we
don't get overthrown because most of us
are by this point democracies
so I think that that Imperial drain or
Colonial drain or whatever you want to
call it
largely ended in the early to middle
part of the 20th century and I think it
was a major factor in the Great
Depression it was a major factor in the
inflation crisis of the 70s if you think
about why we had the inflation crisis of
the 70s a big part of it was the rise in
price of oil which is credited directly
to the fact that the OPEC countries now
controlled the oil instead of us
controlling it through the Seven Sisters
like instead of us colonially
controlling the energy they controlled
it and they decided to raise the price
of oil and that created inflation over
here so I think like a lot can be seen
when you start looking at
the colonial drain and the colonial
drain just started to like run out by
the 60s so we managed to recreate it you
know by replacing like the old school
warship and gun and Bayonet with with
debt and we would just extend debt to
with conditionality to these countries
and and it started with a trickle and
then it really began
with a flood in the 70s McNamara he
really head of the World Bank he really
really realized that like we could get a
lot more influence in the world by
dramatically increasing the amount of
loans we could we could give out and
this was like expedited by the
petrodollar system like that that there
was just so much money parked in Western
Banks from from the OPEC countries and
we were able to loan it out to all these
poor countries and there was just like
if you look at the percentage of loans
to poor countries from rich countries in
the 70s it's insane like you had like a
400 percent increase between like the
mid 70s and early 80s also explain
briefly just backtrack for
um people who are watching this who
haven't read your excellent book um what
exactly are structural adjustment loans
sure what are the characteristics of
them yeah so like let's say if you're
suharto in Indonesia in the 70s and
you're going to take a loan from the IMF
the IMF officials would fly out
first class if it's longer than 10 hours
I think and then the business class same
as some of the Dei Consultants like the
Eber Mexican I mean it's always working
for the IMF was sweet gig I mean you
would stay in five-star hotels they used
to play in the comp they had a deal to
fly in the Concorde there's nuts anyway
they fly to these countries they never
go out to like the field they like stay
in like the nicest Sheraton or whatever
and they do deals with the government
and basically they say look you're
running out of resources you have a
problem with your balance of payments
like you're importing too much and
you're not exporting enough like you're
running out of money uh your reserves
are dwindling will give you a loan like
we'll give you 50 50 million dollars 100
million dollars whatever it is
in exchange you have to do these things
and it's very important to note that
normally like for the great majority of
the loans that were given out they were
given to dictators to unaccountable
leaders so it's not like suharto was
like okay let me take this deal let me
go check with the people let's see if
they can send this was never the case so
like like hey they they were like fine
like essentially and I'll explain the
conditions but like they were like we'll
do we'll implement the conditions just
give me the money they never plan to pay
it back they knew that they they didn't
have to pay it back in fact and they
would spend the money on
um weapons and on security forces and on
palaces and on just general Petty
corruption
um and then maybe a small amount would
get left over to actually fund
infrastructure and like good things for
the people but most of it was just like
drained away from them
um and in return for taking the money
they had to do what the country had to
undergo what is known as like structural
adjustment which is basically austerity
I mean it would start with like
devaluation of the currency it was
always like key uh restriction of the
banking systems like raising interest
rates um and subsidies on any food or
energy there would be for example
um
raising taxes was very common like like
aggressively raising taxes so this is
basically austerity or basically like
you'd want to like plunge the country
essentially into a recession and the the
general idea was like you you want these
countries to
be really efficient at exporting the
goods that we want so you don't want
them to have like high wages with health
care and education you want them to be
really streamlined and to be like cheap
and we want those resources very cheap
to make our lives cheaper on our side so
like generally speaking IMF programs are
designed to prevent western style social
democracies they're designed to prevent
free health care and education they're
designed to prevent even like modest
subsidies on basic Goods but there were
also frequently free trade stipulations
in there too right tell me more what do
you mean well isn't the idea to increase
trade between these you know frequently
former Colonial powers and their oldies
and other countries the idea was to
increase what's known as unequal
exchange so for example
the idea was to to to to keep the
conveyor belt of stuff coming from there
but like those countries aren't allowed
to trade freely like America has
aggressive so the whole the whole like
hypocrisy have a chapter in my book
about this the double standards are
really the crazy part because as someone
who's like identified as a classic
liberal I don't necessarily think
subsidies on food and energy are a good
idea yeah that was the other thing and I
don't think the nationalization of
companies is a good idea yeah but when
you have this double standard where you
have the rich countries doing aggressive
agricultural subsidies and totally
subsidizing health care and education
and then turning to like Little Britain
for example with like the Healthcare
System they have at the NHS and then
they turned to a little Sri Lanka or
Ceylon as it was called and they would
say no you can't get free rights to your
people anymore I mean that that's a
double standard that creates inequality
that's what's this sort of just unequal
right
um and that is what really
exacerbated the issue uh I mean if
everybody was like judged on the same
standard then maybe it would be
different but that's not how it was I
mean one of the main reasons Africa
Imports 85 percent of its food is
because the United States aggressively
subsidizes food production in the United
States so that like a crowds out African
producers and I think another really
really important part of the Bretton
Woods system
and then later the petrodollar system is
that
the United States basically created
military and political pacts to force
producers of really important things to
only sell in dollars so like for like
little Malawi they are like Ghana let's
say Ghana can't print CDs to buy oil
like the amount we can we can just print
money to buy oil Saudi Arabia won't
accept CDs so what does Ghana do if it
wants oil well contrary to what the mmt
people believe
they can't just print CDs for dollars if
they do that they go into hyperinflation
so they have to export stuff to earn
dollars into their Capital account and
then they and then they can buy oil or
dollars or Euros or some sort of dollar
substitute they basically have to
structure their economy to earn dollars
it's the only way they can buy
fertilizer oil tractors Industrial
Equipment they cannot print money out of
like from their own printing press to
buy the stuff
so this structures their economy in a
particular way where they have to focus
their National energy on exports so that
they can get the dollars to pay off the
interest by the oil by the weapons like
Boeing is not going to accept CDs sorry
so it's like this is just the way it
worked so all of these countries ended
up getting like engineered by us so
again the three things that we got out
of the IMF and World Bank over the last
50 60 years were
interest payments cheap labor and
resources
and political control I mean some some
of the political control stuff is so
shocking I'm going to show a slide from
The New York Times from 1978 tomorrow
from Zaire what was then Zaire and it
was very plain the headline just said
um Dyer takes like large loan from IMF
and gives up economic control of its
country so basically the IMF staffed the
treasury Ministry of this country with
its own people like we basically would
take over these countries it's
completely wild we sound like we're
rooted in another era talking about like
Zaire and Ceylon and all these things I
know but the people who live there today
were alive then like it's important to
remember that we're not that far away
from that and that these policies
instead of like it's not like they just
ended in the 90s that the energies I
mean the energies of the IMF did shift
like about 15 years ago but most of
their energy has been spent largely on
the developing world uh it's true that
they shifted to help Europe like the
imf's loans to Europe were way bigger
than any loans it had ever given to
Latin America or Asia
but it was a similar thing if you look
at Greece which was bailed out right one
of these enormous bailouts
I mean if you look at Greek wages Greek
wages are negative since 2008. so like
the IMF programs uh brought wage
deflation to Greece so like the elites
did well in Greece and they were bailed
out but the average person has had a
really rough time
so so like poor European countries were
basically treated like the global South
in this in this in this example
and that's just been a brutal reality
for workers and laborers in these
countries in southern Europe like
literally they're they're their wages
have been deflated and that's that's
kind of that was the point of
colonialism and that's sort of the point
of the IMF and World Bank is to is to
again get cheap resources and cheap
labor you talk a little bit in your book
about how there was a lot of criticism
directed at these institutions back in I
believe the late 90s was huge Seattle
protests like everything did anything
change as a result of that or are we
seeing waves of criticism because it
seems like like if the things that you
were writing about are in fact true this
is a scandal this is an outfit no I mean
it was very clear I mean I mean there's
just many many reasons why it's an
outrage I mean another part is another
reason is that like the people making
the loan decisions like didn't come from
these countries there's a stat I used in
the book from the early 90s where
um again this is 50 years of IMF from
World Bank to that point
um less than one percent I believe of
the decision makers making the loans to
Africa were Africans so it was just a
very Colonial like construct to begin
with but in general
um yes there was a ton of criticism uh
by you know everyone from
not stiglitz to the protesters in
Seattle uh to Libertarians writing for
um Atlas and Cato I mean there was a lot
of discussion and debate about do we
need these institutions
um and a lot of global South leaders you
know uh created conferences like Arusha
and others where they would get together
and like basically condemn the IMF and
it was I would say it reached a fever
pitch like in the late 90s and as a
result in reaction they did pledge to
reform certain things okay so
um
the like like the very very poorest
countries uh can now qualify for like
basically what they call debt relief
where maybe they can get loans that
don't
um
uh have interest and and maybe they can
also get actually write-offs on some of
their debt but what you have to remember
is that these are like 20 or 30 of the
poorest countries in the world that
constitute a small
minority of the total lending of the IMF
like the IMF and the World Bank Target
the big juicy meaty industrial Global
South countries like most of their
lending historically is to Brazil
Argentina Nigeria Indonesia Pakistan
it's not to Bhutan like it's it's to
these big industrial countries that have
tons of resources that's where we milked
the most out of where these bigger
bigger countries so it's true that there
was some reforms for like some of the
very poorest countries in the world but
they still had to they still have to
undergo structural adjustment to get the
money that has not been performed
um and again like like in a way they
changed because their focus shifted you
know for a decade or so to Europe but
after covid all the lockdowns happened
they re-upped and and as a result of the
lockdowns and the money Printing and now
the raising of interest rates the United
States now you're seeing a whole new
Spate of bailouts it's just in the news
every day right so Egypt's currently
getting adjusted Argentina is getting
adjusted gone is getting adjusted
Bangladesh is getting adjusted so you're
seeing a whole new round of
conditionality and people know like it's
not like like my book was written for
Americans and for Europeans I don't need
to I don't need to teach anything to
someone from Ghana they know quite well
what an IMF structural adjustment is and
associated with like small like lower
living standards and just like General
recession this is like they know this
they've lived it they don't need me to
tell them but westerners I think you
need to understand this because we just
like we don't learn about this it's
that's why the book is called hidden
oppression it's not it's not known but
now we're seeing it that that was an
additional incentive for me to write the
book is that you're seeing a whole new
wave of IMF bailouts all around the
world of some of the most brutal regimes
I mean CeCe in Egypt um
the guys committing war crimes in
Ethiopia
hundreds of millions of dollars from the
World Bank
um I mean you name it there's tons of
dictators getting tons of money right
now and I just was like what is going on
here and and it's kind of like again
like a it's like a self-fulfilling cycle
because like we
we we have an inflation crisis in the
west you know we have a monetary crisis
here so the FED raises rates uh the
world is not on the fed's Mandate like
like the impact of raising rates on
Indonesia is not part of what Jay Powell
has to consider when he raises rates
it's entirely self-interested domestic
thing so we raise these rates we jack
rates from like zero close to zero to
five percent or whatever and this just
causes like massive starvation and
suffering across the world like if you
look at the Ft actually does great
reporting on this and I say actually
because they would never publish like
something like I'm I've written but
they'll they'll point out the uh the
data though they'll show you that over
the last two years or 18 months as rates
have risen
and as structural adjustment has been
introduced uh the price of bread in
Egypt has skyrocketed and and it's
really really hard for people to get the
same amount of food that they used to
get like basically what what happens in
wage deflation is that the amount of
time it takes you to earn a thousand
calories of something like beef or rice
or bread goes up instead of going down
and this is contrary to what you'd
expect with human Innovation and
Technology Innovation so like during the
early 70s to the early 90s in a lot of
these poor countries
I mean the dad is crazy and I have a
section of the book about it but I mean
you had countries where like the the the
amount of time it took you to earn as an
average laborer like a thousand calories
of rice would go up by 50 100 instead of
getting more rich and wealthy and
prosperous and efficient we were
squeezing these people and zaire's is
the extreme case because and this is
shocking like so so the structural
adjustment began in the early 70s
so really in 72 it really started moving
um under mabutu and then he was ousted
in around 95 okay so during that time
the country went underwent a lot of
structural adjustment and received about
two billion dollars from the IMF
um and during that time the Zaire which
is the currency of the country uh which
which was worth one dollar in in 72 was
worth one billionth of a dollar in 1995.
now of course there's a lot of reasons
for that but but a major major
underlying reason is because the country
was squeezed and an enormous amount of
resources were taken out of that country
for I mean they have just like the most
incredible resources of rare Earths
minerals uh fossils on all kinds of
stuff rare Timber
everything and and you know that was all
taken out of the country primarily
through debt a ton of diamond mining too
right well I mean just when I say
minerals that's what I mean and and I
mean Loosely I don't know exactly what
black panther is based on but I think
it's a it's clearly like a colonial
reaction to what happened to countries
like the Congo which really should be
wakanda if you think about it I mean the
amount of uranium in there I mean it's
like there's a lot of parallels there
right so between Mobutu and uh kabila it
seems so that will not in fact be
happening yeah and and you know every
loan requires someone to dance with and
that's the crazy part is that these
these loans propped up these dictators
like if the INF didn't exist
and I know we had Cold War reasons you
know we had the African Vietnam we were
we were at the proxy war in Angola like
like there were reasons for us to
support Mobutu but like if the IMF
didn't exist mabutu would not have
lasted until 1995 there's just no way
um but you know you look you look and
you look at just the Marcos and suharto
and Portillo and you just look at all
these dictators and you realize like the
INF prefers to work with undemocratic
clients because it if it works with a
democracy then there's like property
rights and a supreme court and there's
counter suits and there's protests and
it's messy no they just want to work
with someone who can just implement the
the structural adjustment and then they
can move on so this is partly what
explains why they were working with the
CCP and I mean gistu's regime and I also
didn't find the Cold War thing fully
explanatory because they funded a ton of
left to left regimes like in the area
and Tanzania cochesku in Romania uh
mingistu Marxist guy Marxist guy in
Ethiopia so you did the CCP so you look
at it and you realize it's not just uh
they weren't just funding American
Allies so
I mean there was a really great
libertarian book uh
called perpetuating poverty written I
think in like 93-94.
um under the akato and and they they
wrote something that was very uh stuck
with me and it said basically like the
IMF never met a dictator didn't like and
I was just like what so again that
originally sent me down this rabbit hole
but then you realize that
this isn't just a situation harms poor
countries it benefits us tremendously
um yeah well so how does Bitcoin
fundamentally threaten this
yeah so does Bitcoin right that's a
great question I mean the short answer
is we don't know but we do know is that
a couple things
um what we can notice is is that a
Bitcoin adoption data so when we look at
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency adoption data
which which is like overwhelmingly
Bitcoin and stable coins is what we're
really talking about here
um you start to notice when you look at
like just data over the last couple
years that the rate of adoption of these
things in countries that have been
structurally adjusted is just like way
higher than than in the United States
which is much closer to like the global
average which is like internet users
between the age of 16 and 64 10 in
America or so
that have in some way used
cryptocurrency
okay but then you can move over and you
look at Indonesia and Nigeria
Brazil and the numbers are much closer
to 18 19 20 21 22 and then they're
increasing dramatically so you know
that's the big picture like what what
what kind of theories could explain that
is that people are people are Escape I
mean this is one of the reasons why when
the IMF you know in its ongoing
adjustment of Argentina it included a
clause recently saying that like one of
the conditions of this loan is that you
try to crack down on on bitcoin and
cryptocurrency usage and this is one of
the reasons why the IMF was not super
happy about El Salvador adopting Bitcoin
something that you know was announced
here right here two years ago
um they they don't like things that can
like disrupt their ability to like
essentially Farm people under a weak
currency they don't want any Escape they
don't want people buying gold they don't
want people getting access to dollars
they want them to stay in this weak
currency so they could squeeze it and
get wage deflation so bitcoin's an
escape for that so people are escaping
via Bitcoin and stable coins and I think
that's really cool can it change the
overall system nobody knows obviously we
can speculate but but what we don't need
to speculate on what we're seeing real
evidence of is that people have an
escape that they didn't have in the
1980s like if you were being
structurally adjusted in Peru in the
1980s there was no way to sort of Escape
like the currency was the currency and
it was being devalued and and that your
cost of living was going up and up and
up today
you don't have to be stuck in Peru you
can you can escape into Bitcoin or
dollars
um without ID and you can you can you
can preserve your purchasing power or
even increase it over time that's not
something that people had 20 30 40 years
ago so that's really cool again does it
does it change the whole system we don't
know but like one would expect that if
I mean if you look at what's happening
in China right now China's encountering
issues because it can't print the
reserve currency so when a country
defaults on a loan from China like I
mean they have to basically take
something as collateral they have to
like take over a telecom or something it
gets messy and China doesn't necessarily
want to do that so the the their loans
are drying up if you look at the data of
like their infrastructure loans to poor
countries I mean it was absolutely
gargantuan up to like 2016 27 to 2018
and then it's really fallen off so
they're encountering a lot of issues and
I I think that that's evidence to show
that the countries that issue the
reserve currency who control the info
Bank like um
we we can do this in a much more
sustainable way because it's just
paperwork for us to give 30 billion
dollars to Brazil it's not paperwork for
the Chinese to give 30 billion dollars
worth of currency to Brazil that's a
really serious thing they have to think
about but for us it's like paperwork so
if we're not if we're in a world where
we eventually shift to bitcoin being a
reserve currency then yes we no longer
can like do paperwork to bail out Brazil
we have to be quite prudent about it
because it's a scarce resource and we
have to actually think carefully about
it so I think yeah I think there'll be a
lot less of these like infinite bailouts
and less debt traps or at least I'm
quite hopeful of that
I'm curious about one other sort of
related Frontier is the lightning
Network going to fundamentally change
the sending of remittances and receiving
of remittances
I mean I I think this is an interesting
area
um because one of the reasons why
there's so much unequal Exchange in the
world and and so much disparity in Labor
uh is because of the currency divisions
um if you have naira over here and
dollars over here you can you can
effectively like sort of cut these labor
markets away from each other if
everybody's using the same currency and
you know lightning isn't is an easy way
to use
um Bitcoin in an instant way that's
relatively cheap now it's certainly
Nation it needs a lot of work before it
could get to the scale that would
actually change the world but for
individuals and corporations it's making
a big difference already but if but if
all of a sudden like you've got this
Global Community or company let's say
that's all in the same currency standard
I mean that's a game changer I mean I I
think you start to have Arbitrage in
labor like big time uh one of the
reasons you have Arbitrage and Global
labors is because of the currency
divisions again like if you have
everybody's earning the same type of
currency there's going to be a
tightening of the spread you can keep
that spread artificially wide by by
having different currency regimes
there's like 180 currency regimes right
now Africa has 45 currencies it's one of
the reasons it's so poor it get like no
one gets like not connected it's
terrible but if Africa had one currency
and that was the same currency we used
here I have a firm belief that that
would that would that would really
tighten the spread on labor and it would
make exchange much more equal I mean
obviously that's sure speculation but
like no one knows but but that would be
in my view that would make a lot of
sense
well so what's the fix uh specifically
with these institutions do you believe
that they are so far beyond reform and
fundamentally ought to be abolished and
ended or is there a better solution that
you've stumbled upon yeah what do you
see as the end because clearly this type
of almost like predatory lending as you
term it yeah is something that probably
shouldn't continue I don't
um look I wrote the book it just is
almost like an exorcism type exercise to
just like get it out like I don't
um I I
tribute the book I um dedicate it in the
beginning and I I say it's for the
victims of development they may never
get the Justice they deserve but they
may get a way out and that's how I feel
I don't think any of these people who
perpetrated structural adjustment
whatever
go to prison I don't think I mean we're
talking about if you think about the
fact that that under adjustment uh the
country's GDP goes down 10 30 10 20 30
sometimes over a decade and if you you
consider that based on studies on large
countries like Mexico for every two
percent decline in GDP mortality rate
goes up one percent I mean we're talking
tens of millions of people were killed
by these policies and no I don't think
Larry Summers will ever go to prison for
this in fact no one even knows that he
was involved in this he was Chief
Architect of of the economic wing of the
World Bank in the early 90s and he went
to the White House and now he's like
telling us what to do on Twitter like
he's living in a mansion like he's not
going to go to prison for this none of
these people will ever go to prison for
structural adjustment that they
perpetrated on the global South so I
don't think we're ever going to get
Justice
um
but I do think that like people in the
west should should be more aware of what
these institutions do and if they
disagree with my thesis let's have a
debate like I'd like to hear them
explain why poor countries have
exponentially Rising external debt and
I'd like to hear their view on that and
how would they recommend that we we
adjust that I know a lot of leftists
like this idea of like the debt Jubilee
um and it's an interesting one I think
that is certainly something that should
be discussed as far as options it'll of
course never happen and I'll explain why
um when you lend something when you lend
money to it to to Mexico let's say in
the 80s
um the reason why we we went in and
bailed out Mexico wasn't to save
Mexicans it was to save our banks that
had lent that asset that they they
traded an asset on their balance sheet
by lending to Mexico right and then when
that was at risk of going into default
they could do one of two things they
could they could take the right down and
have that go to zero on their balance
sheet or they could lend another loan
and grow their balance sheet and the
incentive is always for these creditors
to grow and grow and lend and lend and
lend rather than accept uh basically a
shrink a shrinking of their balance
sheet so you know we would always go in
um
uh not out of altruism none of these
bailouts Mexico Argentina Korea Thailand
Indonesia they were never done out of
altruism they were done to save our
banking system and prevent it from
going into a crisis so I think that
that's sort of important to realize and
I think that this sort of prevents any
sort of big big reform
um there's no even though the Jubilee
might make sense and there's a concept
called odious debt that actually was
invented by Americans back 100 years ago
when we defeated the Spanish in Cuba
um our there were policymakers in
America that basically said that the
Cubans shouldn't owe the debt that the
Spanish Empire had incurred because they
were subjugating the Cubans why should
the Cubans have to pay but we but the
infant World Bank have never followed
that precedent so for example when a
colonialist got overthrown or a dictator
gets overthrown that people still have
to pay back the debt that the dictator
borrowed so I used the statistic in my
book but in in the middle 80s in the
Philippines when Marcos was ousted by a
people power movement the next year 40
of the national earnings had to go to
pay back interest that Marcos had
borrowed so
there there isn't an incentive to change
based on how the system works and if you
look at the IMF structure it's a
colonial power structure meaning it's
it's based on Colonial 1944 uh Power
Arrangement it's not based on population
so the quota or the or the voting share
is such that like China has a similar uh
voting share to Italy right now uh and
Britain has a similar voting share to
India I mean obviously we know that
there are economies and populations are
not the same anymore
um America retains a unilateral veto of
18 that can be done anything they want
and they even have essentially a
practical unilateral veto over micro
loan decisions which require 50 veto
because if you add up America and all of
its allies we can easily do that so
there's no I don't think you'll see
internal reform so I think I as much as
I'd like to suggest options like that we
do odious debt cancellation like JP
Morgan's not gonna like that like if we
were to go out and cancel all of the
odious debt and we'd have to Define it
somehow it's not like all the debts
odious but clearly the debt that was
lent to mabutu and Marcos and suharto
was odious you'd of course have to have
some sort of wine because I Libertarians
would argue that you know money that
democracies is borrow as odious so you
have to find a line but maybe you could
find a line and just say like hey at
least we all agree that like this
horrible dictator like those people
shouldn't have to pay that ironically
the US did it with Iraq after we invade
it um but like that's an exception we
usually don't allow that so that would
help certainly if you were to actually
write off debt the problem is that would
shrink our banking system so we don't
have any incentive to do that so again I
don't have like high prospects for
reform I do think as Global Bitcoin
adoption increases I think the power of
these institutions wanes and eventually
they they are forced to become smaller
and and more core to their original
Mission as opposed to like sort of
resource extraction machines I think
that they turn back into potentially
like collaboratively managed funds that
do things in the common interest like
put out fires when countries have issues
um I think that that's possible but I
think that's only possible if there's a
reform of the monetary Paradigm if we
remain on this dollar hegemonic system
like there's just no one no one has an
incentive to change this it's just
there's no
I I use this metaphor in the book but
it's like a drug dealer like the the the
Western creditors are dealing drugs to
largely unaccountable governments and
authoritarian countries and there's no
there's no one there to like put you in
therapy like there's no one there to say
maybe you shouldn't take this debt and I
mean you have the additional moral
complication of like
what if you're starving in Kenya or poor
like like you may just want the debt
like you may just want the debt it's a
short-term fix it's like being an addict
like what like if you are an addict like
taking more drugs makes you feel better
for like a day or whatever or an hour or
a minute or whatever so you do more of
it even though you know long term it's
destroying you so if you're living in
Peru or Kenya uh or Bangladesh or Ghana
I mean it may be even though you know
that this is killing you yeah and
killing you meaning like literally like
killing a lot of people you're gonna
take the debt maybe and who am I to say
that you shouldn't you know it's just a
very very difficult moral conundrum I
think so why would countries gravitate
toward use of Bitcoin instead of just
using the dollar I don't think any
country is going to like voluntarily
move from control over monetary policy
to not being able to control monetary
policy uh safety moose has a great quote
it's something like the only thing
dictators
um
uh would hate more than the dollar is
giving up control over their own
currencies like so so if you look at
bouquet you have to understand that that
was a dollarized economy like he already
lost he didn't have control over
monetary policy so to add Bitcoin wasn't
a huge sacrifice for him do you know
what I mean yeah so I think maybe I mean
maybe you expect dollarized countries to
think about Bitcoin also or or countries
that are partially dollarized maybe they
add Bitcoin maybe I don't know but I
think it's very unlikely that countries
that control their own currency
um that they would voluntarily dollarize
or Bitcoin eyes is unlikely I mean I
would really recommend Lawrence Larry
White's new book
um on this topic it's really good and
he's got a lot of expertise looking at
dollarization in Latin America there
were some instances where it was bottom
up
and there were some instances where it
was imposed it's much more likely that
any kind of big like I do think you're
going to see more dollarization first of
all like in the next decade like other
Fiat currencies are collapsing so more
people are just going to use dollars
whether they get them via stable coins
or via bank accounts or via just cash I
don't know but like I think you're going
to see more dollarization
both top down and brought them up but
mostly bottom up but I think if we're
going to think about what would it look
like for countries to actually Bitcoin
eyes I think we have to study Larry's
work we have to look at what happens
when countries Grassroots dollarize like
uh Cuba in the 90s or Venezuela or
Ecuador for example and I think what
starts to happen is you start to have
this sort of aggressions law scenario
where you have the legal tender
um and and people don't don't want it
it's like not great uh meaning they
don't want to save in it they know it's
weak so so they'll save in something
else so they'll hoard gold or dollars or
whatever this comes from the days of
like coin clipping with Kings where they
would like clip out the gold and the
citizens would notice which coins were
clipped and it would save those and use
the others the others others would
circulate the
um bad money would drive out the good
okay
um I think that that's kind of like
probably
gonna happen with Bitcoin for a while
like if you can afford to save your
Bitcoin you're going to save it like
you'd rather spend the Fiat right it's
sort of obvious like like I would much
rather spend Fiat than Bitcoin if
possible but I think eventually this
changes if you study Larry's work with
dollarization you'll see that what
eventually changes this is Merchants one
day the merchant is going to say like
for example today some Merchants like
prefer cash to to digital cash and
they'll they'll say um I'll give you a
discount if you pay me in cash like
you're doing work on your house and
you've got a guy coming in to do your
floors he may actually accept a small
discount if you pay him in cash because
people like the finality of cash there's
certain benefits of cash obviously
taxation other things
um but but they they'll actually like
prefer cash to to to a check often right
so I think you could start seeing this
with Bitcoin eventually like one once
Merchants are like you know what I want
the Bitcoin and in fact if you pay me in
Bitcoin will offer a small discount and
eventually the merchants in these
countries might just say no I just I
don't take Fiat anymore I just want your
Bitcoin that's how you'd have hyper
bitcoinization it would it could only be
through this process of merchants
demanding it and and spreading through
the economy and that's something called
tiers law which is the opposite of
gresham's law which is the good money
drives out the bad and that's ultimately
I think what you'd have you'd have to
have something like that happen to see
something like actual Bitcoin spread in
an economy and I think it's a Grassroots
thing I don't think it's possible to
impose as we've seen in El Salvador I
don't think it works like people
people don't like to be bitcoin's weird
it's different it's totally strange and
mysterious and they think it's a scam
and in general like they don't
necessarily want it like they like all
these people who got the handouts in El
Salvador most of them just sold it for
dollars like they're just it's just
weird and different when I went down
there I met people who
like they were taking their tips and
saving it in Bitcoin but like their
salary they wanted a dollars like and
maybe they were smart to do that like
short term right so um I think that it's
gradual and I think that over time it's
it's it's probably a bottom-up process
like I don't think you see governments
choose to top down dollars or Bitcoin
eyes unless they really have to and and
I think that when they have to is when
you start seeing them collect tax
revenue in a different currency that's
when they've given up so in Venezuela
they actually gave up and
they're changing it now they're going
back and forth based on their economic
condition but when the Venezuelan
government was was taxing people in
dollars that's when you know they've
given up on the Fiat and it dies so you
just have to see what happens like will
one day governments just say we're gonna
tax and pick on them then you know that
then you know the fiat's dying but I
don't know I mean we never get there
thank you so much thank you I really
appreciate that
foreign